you
[Music]
hello everyone thank you so much for
coming we are very happy to have with us
professor Miroslav Styron from the
University of Gothenburg and Sharma's in
Gothenburg Sweden he's gonna talk to us
today about his work on autonomous AI
based measurement systems and Ericsson
Volvo and a bunch of other companies so
without much further ado all right great
thanks
first of all thanks for having me
really appreciate coming over to
Microsoft Research so Who am I I'm not
yet professor in software engineering
work mostly with the software
measurement from different areas and
mostly working with companies like
Ericsson and Volvo on that I'm also
active in standardization committees
most recently in 25,000 standards and
the revision of those when there's a
basically the pictures of things that we
are doing together with in this case
Ericsson Volvo so different kind of
dashboards and measurement system for
for decision support and I brought the
book that we wrote together with we'll
have my colleague you can browse it and
I will leave the copy with the nachi and
and yeah so this is basically our team
it's both it's both for academia from
academia and Industry and both me and VM
have been working together for the past
12 13 years now on measurement systems
we actually both we located about 200
metres away from each other to different
places so we work a lot on on software
measurement and the context of the whole
collaboration is the Software Center
which is 11 companies and 5 universities
and it's a collaboration that is quite
similar to what you have at Microsoft
Research but a bit different of course
it's more companies it's more
universities and it's focused on things
like continuous delivery on architecting
on measurement and management and
customer data and ecosystems working
with companies like Volvo ground force
that are makers of pumps
a person who is working with maps motion
zoom as you know of course not
so a what we're so excited about working
with the software Center is because
gives us an opportunity to work some in
a very different way than most academic
research is done so since this is a
formalized agreement we have the
possibility to go to one company test
the idea and after a while go to another
company test the idea and improve that
father and then move on to more and more
companies so this is how we basically do
we take for instance the code churning
that
Nachi and that some of your colleagues
have written while back and we applied
at at Ericsson and then a colleague of
mine Robert just introduced me to heat
maps so we used heat maps to visualize
turning in the logical product base and
after while we took that idea from
Ericsson to to SAP where they basically
said that well if you can visualize that
maybe you can also predict the coming
changes or predict changes that should
be done but we're not done so we did
this that we call the change wise and
based on that when we took it to Volvo
tracks we could also predict the impact
of change waves and the code churning on
on the quality both of the quality on of
the code but also quality of the final
track that is driving around and then in
the end we took it to devolve a course
we could actually bring in both defects
and requirements and code into one one
dash board that could predict a wave of
changes in the requirements that would
spread to the source code that would
spread to the test cases that would
spread to the quality so we could be we
could as it basically predict the things
about half a year in advance on it that
this kind of work resulted in roughly
40,000 measurement systems that we built
at different companies and I will
introduce you to to what a measurement
system is later on but you could see
this for example as a type of air you
could see this as a gadget which
visualizes some sort of measurements
that are being processed in completely
autonomous way based on either big
databases Excel or bi behind it that has
mechanism
for self-healing so that those forty
thousand measurement systems if they
crash they could actually repair
themselves so this infrastructure of
forty thousand people is maintained of
by roughly two-and-a-half person per
year which is very little given their
given amount of work of the do so in
spite instead of thanks to the
self-healing that we did was that they
instead of spending hours a week they
could spend hours a month on maintaining
those things and then focus on new
development we have worked a lot with
the things about information quality so
if you see a number at the very top the
defect backlog eight and you see the red
dot that red dot is actually showing if
you can trust the number or not so even
if though you can mathematically get a
number of defects there could be a lot
of properties for instance the database
might not have been updated the defects
are outside of the limits so so even if
you see eight maybe you could expect
twenty so where are the the other
missing defect and so on so we build a
lot of check into the data that gives
the stakeholder some understanding if he
or she could trust that information on
it and then we of course have
estimations of things for instance we
applied those change waves analysis at
at Volvo so we could predict if if a
change in a standard of of AUTOSAR how
much that would cost to implement in a
new Volvo car and that analysis was
usually done during a few months but
thanks to darker and his work we could
do it in days they could press a button
get a lot of information build a model
and then they could just evaluate if
that model was correct or not and then
of course what we also did is we could
also apply exactly the same things to
look at the quality of requirements so
we could pinpoint requirements that did
not fulfill specific criteria very early
during the review so if you could review
a you know a specification with a
hundred thousand requirements instead of
spending weeks of reading all of them
and trying to build a mental model that
that tool would allow you to focus on
say two hundred requirements that are
really but really need your attention
maybe they are not consistent or they
are not coherent or they need some extra
extra information or maybe they
they're just wrong plane and use it so
that was what we did quite manually now
what we doing right now is focusing a
lot of applying this machine learning
techniques and artificial intelligence
and measurement so quite normally when
you when you have a measurement
programming in a company you take a lot
of data and try to build up some
decision support you could see this as a
bi for instance right it's an example of
it but that requires a lot of manual
effort to find out what the questions
are you know who does what does the
stakeholder want who is the stakeholder
yeah yeah what their goals are and and
what kind of measurements you do but if
you if we apply mesh for example machine
learning or AI those systems could
basically tell you what is it that you
need to focus on so in a case of a
company who has forty thousand
measurement systems and maybe hundreds
of thousands of measurements the AI
could pick out those measurements that
are off limits today and focus your
attention so if you for instance focus
too much on quality and then forget that
the important part is to ship the
features in your product the measurement
system will start flagging that you're
lagging behind in the feature
development or vice versa edge if you
just focus on new development but don't
test enough they say I will tell you
that now you should really focus on
testing because your test progress is
slowing down and because you know
because of that they suffer from quality
and so on it could also give you a lot
of simulations on that and where we came
from is that we started with working on
the manual predictions a long time ago
we build a lot of prediction models
together with erickson and then we found
out that those predictions are very good
but they are very unreliable in many
cases because they are very product
specific it's very difficult to build a
uniform model that will predict number
of defects in any product in the world
so what we came up with was that we
could automate certain quality checks
look for example of if the variables or
metrics are outside of Linux and if they
are outside of Linux we could tell you
that okay this is the model that you can
use you will get a number but you
shouldn't trust a number because their
values are outside of the range that are
usually predicted for that and we
that we focus on mostly things like
defect or false failures in the product
and then we said that that's of course a
very good thing but it's a very reactive
thing so we moved on to called stability
visualization where we used the code
churning and basically characteristics
of code churning to make prediction
models and then we could build up things
like robust measurement programs based
on that so be able to predict and warn
stakeholders a few months before
something happened that that you're
going to have problems with this product
you're gonna have problems with this
module or you're gonna have problems
with with that type of customers and
then what we do today is we do this AI
based software analytics when we
building a lot of intelligence in there
in the measurement codebase so instead
of spending years and months to bring up
to analyze your data the AI gives you
the answers directly by itself so to say
and that brings me to - how do we do
that right so we if you take companies
like Ericsson a Volvo or any other
company that work they have something
they call measurement program right so
they have stakeholders they have
information needs they measure things
they measure product they measure
processes productivity quality and and
aspects like that and they try to put
them as key performance indicators to
put on big monitors and show you know
how good are we today I mean how many
customers did we get how many customers
do we lose but those are very reactive
they are set up by people who have a
domain knowledge and these people based
all of that on their experience but as
you know the world is not built on
experience the world is changing all the
time so if you build things based on
your experience quite often you are can
miss something so what we do is we
provide more decision support to to
exchange experience with some new ideas
so we bid for example algorithm ace on
decision trees to come up with new new
metrics and that will tell you that this
is an aspect that you don't really cover
based on applied statistics and things
like that and we do this
and we do this quite often we have a
repository of over 2000 different
metrics that we constantly increase and
show the fad aspect of what we do we
have this cell this self-healing
infrastructure that that does it I mean
imagine if you're a process in this
amount of data you cannot really
manually monitor that everything is
right all the time so what we have is we
have this the systems that do a lot of
magic behind the scenes looking at for
instance : reality of data so the
mathematical properties of the data it
looks at the processes behind the data
for instance have people been reporting
defects into the system have test cases
been executed have code been checked
into the repositories all kinds of
things and based on those aspects we
could tell that for instance something
has happened in the data that for
example people have stopped checking in
the coating to get repository meaning
that one has to look look into that and
and decide if that's something that we
should ignore or is that something that
is not required yes so in practice that
means that sometimes if you measure
something you get say the closest
example if someone doesn't doesn't
report a defect you may get a division
by zero somewhere right and in normal
cases you could visualize that idea as
an you know infinity or error or zero
but that even if that's a number it
doesn't mean that it's that it's a
correct number so the self what the self
feeling does is that it looks into why
did we get a missing defect and if
that's for example a missing connection
to a database it will try to pull the
database few more times to try to get
the data and maybe the database needs to
be restarted so the self-healing
mechanism knows that it's a database it
could be restarted that way so it
restarts the database and that's a lot
of those kind of checks and in most
cases can fix the problem with the
missing data
the
in a much more meaningful way than just
serving zero on that applications from
your perspective that would be mostly
applications we don't do operating
system we don't go that deep all right
all right let me move on then and and
that is important with this because this
is how a measurement system could be
visualized right so it's everything from
mobile phone apps gadgets in all times
to websites to built-in continuous
integration or you know things that
based on sonar cube or on tableau
dashboards or power bi all kinds of
systems but that's just a visualization
that the final step right what we want
what we do with the AI or our machine
learning is that we change those
visualizations automatically so in the
old days one could see that this was a
take this picture and that was a
measurement system showing bottlenecks
in a software development program so it
was divided by phases and what could
look at different activities and the
throughput and queues and flow in the
system but as you see that's quite
cluttered right it's a many different
diagrams and and you know don't really
know where to look for so what we do
today instead of that is we take away
that picture and then let the machine
learning look at decision trees and and
regression models to look at their
dependencies between different metrics
and then based on the deviations from
dependencies we could basically say that
for instance now you have a lot of Q in
the defect handling right so we
visualize only this part and say you
should focus on that but if you have a
little defects but a lot of for example
develop a lot of development and all of
integration we could visualize something
that's not on this diagram that is a
testing saying that okay you have
developing a lot things are happening
but we don't see any defects meaning
that there must be something wrong with
your testing so look at your testing are
you testing enough are you testing the
right thing or you may be mixing test
cases where are the things that you
I mean try to find out where are the
things that are not really visual I said
not really there
yes about training the most direct
attention so what we what we do is that
at the beginning we train that on
historical data but then we have we have
a model that over time looks at when we
should stop using this particular
trained model and should we train the
data so we have an assemble learner that
over time changes the so trains the
model we basically see us on the on the
decision trees and the random forests
and over time when we see that this
model is is getting a bit off charts
then we take away that and we train that
on new model continuously so to say I
mean at some point you must have a label
that says this metric is important at
this moment so we have two things one it
comes from from for example lamp
information quality when we notice that
sometimes for instance this this data is
show it's been off the chart for example
that we expect the defects to be no more
than say 10 per day but now we just have
20 every every week so that lamp is
going to go read a bit more and more and
then someone looks at that and say okay
should we retrain the model or should we
go to the to the team and say look
what's wrong with your testing so that's
one aspect the other aspect is that if
we get a new data type for instance or
new metric or or we could call it a new
feature for there for the model then we
try to retrain the model based on some
simple algorithm and then we use active
learning when when things when they
regret for example random for is give us
a high probability that deserve that
doesn't the Algrim doesn't know where to
classify that aspect then the Quality
Manager or team leader has to press the
button is that okay or not okay so for
the beginning we learn using basically
after active learning so those two
things information quality and active
learning
all right so yeah I mean if it comes to
this information quality and we look at
two things one so the one I talked about
is the more internal quality when we
look at the kind of mathematical
properties of the data but we also look
at the external quality what does the
stakeholder think about the data so this
situation when when the metric is out
outside of the limits and it's all based
on the I sub 59:39 standard which is a
standard showing how the information in
a measurement system flows basically
from the attributes or products until
the information needs of the stakeholder
how that thing is built up and this
whole monitoring of the information
quality now this is just a set of checks
this whole monitoring is based on
checking properties of every step of
that calculation to some yeah that's a
basic idea and then if something goes
wrong like this one for instance that
this check says that the raw data was
not updated for example someone did not
report any defects yesterday then that
will be more for a information system
designer but for there for define for
the stakeholder who just show red
without saying exactly what is the
problem because the stakeholder think
about for instance project manager the
product manager doesn't know exactly
which role data is used and how that is
used and so on so he only gets the
indication that for this moment you
cannot really trust that number but the
metric design you can go in he also gets
a number that number on his or her
screen and he can go in and check
exactly which data was not was not
updated and and what to what to do about
that right and as I said it's based on
the ISO 59:39 standard and how we do
machine learning in that is that we add
a lot of things around that basic idea
of checks right so if you have a lot of
checks you could use the checks as
labels for for training of machine
learning to some extent and we basically
do this data collection so that was what
you saw it simplified on the right hand
side and
the left-hand side is the other things
that are connected to the organization
for example how do we know that a
specific KPI
is really important for that particular
organization how do we know that that
the company X has to focus on speed and
not on quality wait what what does it
say and then we look at for example of
reference models from from other
industries or other companies and try to
compare them and see that Company X is
much slower than Company B and then
Company B is in the same in the same
area but they could develop a lot faster
or integrate a lot faster and there
comes this strength of the collaboration
we have in the software center who have
different companies that are quite open
to each other so we could compare and
they could learn from each other and
they could say look in our model we
could integrate within say half an hour
and you could integrate with and you
need a week to integrate your software
so there is a possibility for
improvement on that and thanks to those
all this work that we did based on code
churning from you for instance we could
teach the models to find where the
problems in the code could actually pop
up based on the dependencies between the
cultures and for example testing so we
have a model a regression model that
shows where are the missing test cases
or which test cases we could suggest to
execute based on a change in a specific
code module we also have this we also
work on the measurements and their
quality from the perspective of the
impact that they have on the company so
for example we look at the entire
measurement program and an entire
measurement program could have maybe up
to 500 measurements in them or
indicators and we look and try to
identify which of the indicators of the
leading ones so if you could only pick
10% of your indicators so 15 indicators
out of 500 which 50 would you pick which
50 are the most important ones and you
could look at of course at mathematical
properties like collinearity and
codependency
and try to predict one on one another
but what could what you could lose is of
course the the slight deviations when
there for instance you have two
indicators and they are in 99 percent of
the weeks there they show the same
status but this one percent of the weeks
when they actually show different status
and that's one percent when it's really
important so we do a lot of work with
the stakeholders when they provide us
with different weights of different
measurements or measurement aspects in
the measurement program and based on
those aspect what we what we do is we
could also build them all the saying
that even if mathematically two
indicators are correlated the important
thing is to show when they deviate from
one another that sort of one percent
when they are not when the correlation
is not perfect on that and it again
helps us a lot if we're part if we're
working with multiple companies when we
do a lot of work with different sectors
different types of stakeholders and
different type of metrics and types of
metrics for example this is a our metric
portfolio sort of summary the areas
which we which we use for example we
have cloud computing measurements things
like anything from stability of a cloud
environment to complexity of the code
that is behind the cloud execution
scalability and so on but also projects
project metrics for example how fast we
deploy new features on the customer site
how fast we test how many reviews we do
we look at the product we look at
organizational performance for instance
how fast can a feature go from an idea
to actually implement it feature and
ship to a to a customer which is
important in in areas like telecom or or
automotive today we look at the customer
site for example product delivery how do
we know that the customer is actually
happy with the product delivery and I
know that you work with that a lot but
but in the areas when for example
automotive is not as easy because you
ship the car and then it sits out there
driving so we don't really collect the
same kind of data it's not the website
them not connected all the time so it's
difficult to find that kind of
information but then we have models and
things that help us out with this and if
you're interested I quit I could show
you more about those metrics and they
come mostly from I do different papers
or from the empirical evidence of the
companies that we work with so we look
at what they are measuring today and
what they know what works and what
doesn't work which could be quite a lot
of good evidence and instead of
predicting I mean see previously we have
focused a lot on predicting the values
of metric for example the defects we
wanted to predict when the defects would
come and how many would come in a
specific product what we should do where
they would count so the location of the
defects but right now what we try to
predict this we try to predict the sort
of events rather than rather than things
related to to defect so the numbers are
not no longer important what is
important is the trend are we going to
be better in in a week or two or are we
going to be worse should we prepare for
something or we should not on it which
sort of is the entry point of course to
all of the mathematics behind this but
it's communicated in much much easier
way so to say so this is showing a
gadget it's roughly ten years old yeah
roughly ten but today we use
mobile phone apps and we use emails
instead of gadgets so the stakeholders
don't have to look at anything at all
they will just get an email when
something is out of range or they can
get an SMS or or on a plink in a mobile
phone on that which is a tremendous
difference because then we could monitor
more and more data and for that we need
this machine learning algorithms would -
to monitor and then we only support the
stakeholders when something is really
required and really needed for that yeah
and of course we used a lot of
mathematics behind that so so very
simple formulas that are not based on so
this is an old formula showing
how many weeks how many weeks are needed
to ship the software to a customer so in
that case it's it's a work we did with
Ericsson
so if the customer to Eric's on calls
and say I want to have the latest and
greatest they need to know how many
weeks they need to actually provide him
with the latest and greatest software
and on their side and then they can also
have this on on a mobile phone app how
that works in this and that was a that
was about eight years ago when we
started working with that that was very
good because it showed a very succeed
and very compact way of showing them off
showing the quality of the product and
and the plan of deployment of that but
that wasn't enough what was required was
to have a more prediction view of that
so what we did in one of the studies is
that we actually used heat maps to look
at the profile of the cult so we would
like to know where do people do changes
in the code base and how do they do that
and you could see two patterns in that
example this is an other software
development where you see the the
intensity of the color basically says
how much code was changed for a
particular week a particular module and
as you seen an agile development you
have changes all over the place on that
but this is an example of a product
which is more a platform versus
application based and you see that quite
quite a lot that there is a group of
people working with a platform and they
do a lot of work all the time as in
those cases and then you see fragments
of the code which are basically
different applications and there you see
a completely different patterns you see
not to read all over the place but you
see blobs when they focus on a specific
feature that is our specific application
in that area and then they move on to
another one and so on and so on and and
this way of visualizing this was
actually a big hit show in the that you
could predict things for example a
missing updates so if you look at the
big middle of that heat map one can of
course start ask
the question why don't we do anything in
that area what's the area for and if
historically you build a model saying
that there are some changes in this area
and as you see that those dots are you
should sometimes have this property that
one because one happens before the other
so you could actually try to build a
model as I said the code change wife
saying that if always this module has
changed the week before that module I
mean why don't we have that change in
some week so you could identify missing
changes for example right and they don't
have to be missing changes but it's a
definitely an input for someone to look
at that code and say look if you have
usually make change to module B after
you make a change in module a why
haven't you done that this time that
kind of way of visualizing code also
helps their teams to prioritize test
cases so they could look at this model
and say so you know now in this
particular week we work very much in
those in those two modules have we
tested those modules at the same speed
or have we tested another part of code
how do we know that the code qualities
is so good on that so input to the
decision and at the beginning we had
this as a manual input right now we
build in more of a prediction models
that could tell that for instance if we
have exactly the same heat map but on a
test cases we could show that in the
same week we have usually made a change
in module a and then usually test K test
case X have reacted on that sort of
found a defect we could prioritize test
cases based on culture nning and and try
to provide this as a feedback to the
test leader saying look this is how your
test strategy should should be designed
in the next few weeks if your changes
are going to be like that and that that
kind of approach led us also to looking
at the standards for the automotive so
darker who is working for Volvo has been
looking at changes in the auto service
standard which is a huge standard kind
of like an operating system for a car
you could see this that way and what he
could do with there with his with his
chain
waves and when this optimization of the
cult we could he could predict the
impact of a particular change in the
standard on the cost of a development of
a car so that standard could say that
for instance we add one attribute to
some some construct or some function in
this say operating system and he could
predict how much that will cost the
company in terms of change management in
terms of new development is the new new
version of the operating system or
standard going to be backward compatible
with the software we have and so on and
so on
but he could also do is that he could
look at the Pareto front and could
identify the the best combination of
features so if you develop the car and
say I want to have this particular
feature you could find that in this and
say ok if I won't have this feature all
of these features I get for free because
I still need to develop that because of
that particular feature right so that
gives you a discovery of new business
possibilities when you develop those
kind of big systems right
and then we talk about you know 100 to
200 different computers and tens of
thousands of different functions in a
car so it gets pretty complex with that
and thanks to this to these analyses of
the changes he could basically quickly
predict and provide more information to
people and he on that and based on that
model he could also say that if we want
to implement say this feature and you
know how what's the cost to implement
the next one and what is this difference
so what do we get if we move on to the
next level so to say right and
identified also they're the sort of
optimum when we no longer what a cost is
basically much more than the benefit
that you get from those features that
you ship to the customers which is
pretty pretty interesting for car
manufacturers but on the other hand he
looked at the very same similar thing
but he looked at that from the
perspective of requirements right so if
you have a hundred thousand requirements
specification you would like to quickly
find out the requirements that are
connected that are
incoherent that are really badly written
to focus our effort on that so he
developed that that model based on on
simple measurements of requirements kind
of like a very very basic natural
language processing but without any
semantics and he could build that part
of the tool tool chain at the company so
right now when this company is is
working with requirement when they
specify the requirement they get it
directly a very quick feedback saying
how good or how bad that requirement is
and they also could get an impact of why
this is this is a good or a bad
requirement very quickly I could give
you an example of that is for instance
if you are implementing something and
then you say that in in your new track
you should implement standard 25 zero 26
which is a very nice requirement if you
write it but then you open up the
standard 25 0 26 that's like 2,000 pages
so what do you mean by implement the
standard you know in fact this which
page so this model would catch this
situation as I look in this requirement
there's something fishy it looks very
nice but it's very in specific right you
need to be very clear about which page
or which area of the standard you should
implement this so to say which saves the
companies hundreds of engineering hours
in in backtracking requirements that
should be specified a bit better at the
beginning of of that of the development
cycles something that my colleague Marek
is working on mostly is now looking at
deck so if you if you look at the
professional companies that develop
software like you you have coding
guidelines what people can do and cannot
do in the cult and you can use of course
style checkers to check many of those
but many of the guidelines cannot really
be done using style checkers because
writing the rule for that would be very
very difficult it's it's not
straightforward to do that so what my
colleague is doing is his building a
machine learning model to train how to
recognize violations in the design
providing examples of a code so when you
do a review and get it you look at that
the code that's been reviewed and say
this is a good code that is a bad code
and then this machine learning algorithm
learns which is a good and bad code so
the next time you'll get you get a
supporting Garrett saying look this is a
probably rule violation in that code or
that code looks good to me so over time
that review speed gets very very very it
gets very very much shortened because
you don't have to read the code anymore
the machine learning algorithm gives you
a good example of what is a violation or
not on it and of course in since this is
all based on probabilities you never get
hundred percent correctness right so we
if we look at how how far we can go for
very big code bases for we need to train
an algorithm we say roughly 300 lines of
code and then we get roughly 70%
accuracy in recognizing which for a
company that does review on a daily
basis is is a lot of it's a lot of speed
up because they get two out of three
lines that they identify this actually
true positive and one line is false
positive but that's okay because they
still can can take this distant on their
own and the novelty of this is that what
we do is we don't use any static models
is we would teach the machine learning
based on the couch so we showed them the
algorithm the code and we tagged the
lines which are good and which are bad
and then it builds a model by itself
looking at things like which words are
used what kind of patterns are used in
the code and what kind of how long the
lines are how many brackets one uses in
the line of code and things like that
yeah and again thanks to thanks to the
collaboration with different companies
in the software Center we could test
exactly the same rules at different
companies and look at how they think
about coding violations because I know
if you do code reviews but but if you've
done code review you know the rules look
very simple on paper but then if you
look at the code and have to
decide if if a rule is violated or not
it's not always that straightforward
because sometimes there is still quite a
lot of interpretation how the rule
should be done and thanks to this
machine thanks to using machine learning
and decision trees one could actually
backtrack how things are working and
when things going bad so to say you
awfully quiet I mean you don't have any
questions or you've already done that
right okay so I'm preaching to the choir
what we did also is we studied the
patterns of how information and
information is actually spread across
the companies so instead of having big
monitors at landscapes that everyone
looks at and no one really gets a lot of
information from we studied who is
communicating with whom in a company and
then we could divert the informational
directing information directly to the
people who are interested on that so
looking at could be through email
communications could be through the
dashboards that are automatically adapt
where people sit different things right
yeah and then we also look at things
when people build that word so think
about for example if they have to decide
between using a power bi or or a gadget
or an email how do they decide today
well well today they basically look at
what the purpose of that is and find out
what they want to do but what they we
have this model that helps them to
choose quite quickly so it's like you
can see like a slider when you configure
buying a new car or buying a new mobile
phone we do it exactly the same thing
for a dashboard so you do play around
with different parameters and then by
the end of the day you get an idea about
what kind of dashboard you you are
building and it could also help you in
some cases to choose what kind of
measurements one could use based on
studying those patterns we also found
out that instead of working with
measurements in terms of dash
it's quite many people actually want to
work with measurements in terms of a
cloud so they would like to have their
own private measurement system put into
a in our own cloud environment which is
extremely simple but still quite
powerful and then spread their
information to other colleagues in an in
a very simple way and that will be
automatically updated and automatically
spread out we found out that it could
reduce up to 50% of the cost of the of
the measurement for the company and then
increase of course empowerment of the
teams who want to have their own
measurements instead of having a central
body steering that that is based of
course on very simple technology so it's
not like a dual cloud it's much much
simpler it may be 100 I'm sorry one
thousand lines of code of the cloud
environment that we use sorry now I
think that's not a lot that's extremely
simple crowd right but it's extremely
powerful for that particular purpose
right because what it basically does
it's spreads around different messages
to different agents and then tells them
to update measurement systems right so
it's extremely extremely simple but
extremely powerful and the things that
we have we have discovered thanks to
that that kind of environment was that
it's much more robust to to changes in
the environment so for example if one
computer goes down it's extremely easy
to just recover the measurements in the
previous architecture which we had was
much more server base so we had to have
backups and things like that now all of
that is of course automatically because
you have you have it in the cloud so you
have a lot of the same code the same
kind of computers that are now using
exactly the same kind of measurement so
you can really easily get it back so to
wrap up yeah that's what we do together
with my colleagues this autonomous
measurement systems that change
themselves that change the way the
companies work with measurement instead
of having dedicated large teams to
maintain measurements we could achieve
that with very very small teams
and I'm not fan of size of the team but
that the size of the team of course the
term is the cost of the measurement
program and in every company the
measurement program is not really
something that that you sell right
I mean Ericsson doesn't sell measurement
system they sell telecom notes Evolver
doesn't say sell measurement system they
sell cars right so they would like to
have this same information with as
little cost as possible and that's
exactly what we are what we are doing so
maximizing the benefit with with the
minimum cost and on it so without thanks
a lot if you have any questions or any
feedback I'll be super happy to hear
that
thanks and be you learn something from
company a and you want to use it on
Company B it's company a okay with you
taking learnings and applying it to
Company B most of the nest and then in
sub percent with us transferable model
yes because in the best of ways will be
desolate see what were housing on their
way of measuring somehow now the
liability of the friction has gone up
why would they want to let this
information go and be useful for the
computers they can make better safe and
reliable carves that's the right people
yes but but in the soft perceptor the
whole thing is built on the idea of that
there are no no competitors inside and
if you want to join us of presenter all
the companies have the right to veto so
for example if you have a Volvo in
software center and then BMW would come
over and say I want to be part of that
Volvo could easily say is sorry their
competitors refer to that so they cannot
join so all the companies that are in
that collaboration are not competitors
meaning that you know they work in
different domains so from this example a
and B are not competitors that is what
they are willing to say later
and of course they don't share all of
the data completely open for example
right so Balak son doesn't give source
go to Volvo and vice versa right they
could meet on the workshop and show each
other their code but they're not giving
that to them right yeah
how often do you see that models need
tweaking suppose you're building like I
don't know estimated defects model
affordable and you want to apply it in
addiction does it apply off the box or
is that a fair amount of manual tuning
that goes on they can a sense is the
methodology the same or is the model
itself just the same you just take the
same coefficients and packet now it's
mostly the methodology that is the same
all of the companies have even though
they have maybe in some cases very
similar set up of tools they do things
differently so for example just the
sheer number of test cases that they
have could be so different that the
coefficient would not make sense so
based on that TV but the methodology is
the same thing and of course if you look
at how how much effort is spent on
coming up to the model of course the
coming up with a methodology first and
trying out different models is what it
takes time right and then if you know
exactly what kind of steps you can do
it's much easier to replicate it takes
maybe 10 percent of the time of the
original times of the same
so every model is getting retrained
every time you wanna transfer the
technology during your company for
example writing better code earlier
I can imagine writing code for
telecommunication commonly you can meet
a friend I'm writing code for an auto
mobile government so then you have to
wonder me or ask the company to be fully
engaged again from the beginning and we
train the models yeah yeah that's true
so if you look at this particular
example of that and what we are so happy
about is that you know it takes only
five trials so the size of five learning
cycles to get to pretty decent accuracy
of the model right because every company
even within the same company different
products have different coding
guidelines you know some products are
written in C some products are written
in C++ you know they have completely
different rules so what we are focusing
on is to minimize this so ideally we
would have you know just one run show me
their code and then I teach them all of
them that I run it but that's that's
maybe your topic we cannot do that so
after five we need to have at least
today five roxrite of doing that and the
whole idea that we are working on is as
I mentioned we have an ensemble learning
so that over time the rule the rules
will change and then the model will also
change so to say so right now we're
trying to find out the breakpoint when
the model should actually automatically
adjust one is the model not good enough
anymore
so that the model could think about it
or come up with that idea by itself but
the Dare training is really important
because the rules are extremely
different and they call how they apply
and how they understood they they also
very different metrics
now the metrics inside here they are
identical for all the companies right
they're very a set of features that we
using the model they're exactly the same
but but you know how you write the code
for example how do you use capital
letters or underscores will differ from
company to company from product to
product the data types that here you is
also differ so instead of coding that
heart into the machine learning we try
to find to extract that so we use things
like bag of words to understand which
language you basically use right what is
a variable what is a type what is a name
what is a function and if you look at it
if you just analyze the code of course
the keywords will pop up much more
frequently than any other words because
keywords are the same but the name was a
variables change so we learn you know
using those kind of techniques so you
may be you that never cleave and prefer
the language yes exactly yes
and in some cases you can even depends
of course on the rules but in some cases
you use rules that you trained on Java
code on the C++ code because they are
not that much different in some cases
yeah so are these chicks for code they
are only trying to find it's a
unintended you know bad code mistake
somewhere you know change variable how
are you trying to like how will you go
about trying to detail it's a malicious
fun in the code right let's in the case
of diesel cars they were updating the
variables so that it reports lower
emission that actually does this was
maliciously put in time so the software
which is known for code qualities are
going to catch them how will you catch
that kind of power doctor I don't really
know because we didn't do we didn't work
with that but I guess if you have
examples of a code that does this thing
that could be could be applicable as
well but we have not done with those
kind of a beginner because if you have
seen never get the values for these
variables always bring the range of 0 to
50 and suddenly there's a new update to
the coding which makes this value 5000
who your systems like that right now
right now if that's not it that's not
the part of the coding guidelines and
people work so much on this project it's
only two people working actively other
women in the whole measurement system we
are I think 1520 people in the team both
in academia industry and in academia we
focus mostly on the development of their
okay you know the the meat of that so
the other ones and our colleagues from
industry they usually work on applying
that so they will take that and apply
that and see if that works for them or
not to give us feedback and help us
train the models we will find let her
say the models
I haven't then you just release it and
the development team implemented collect
all the data yep
it was part of the top you talk about
robustness something that's trying to
figure out which measurement should be
more indicative obvious but everybody
wanna black what models you use for that
because I can imagine those those being
thousands of measurements that might be
correlated not correlating them what
kind of models are you use to figure out
these connections between the
measurements either I mean we use
extremely simpler models so we start
with a PCA and look which variables are
culinarily correlated and then we
provide that feedback to the
stakeholders and look those kind of
variables they always in the same the
same component for example and then they
would say yeah but you know this metric
for example should only be identified
when it's not correlated with something
else so we don't want we don't want to
see both of them in there in the
measurement system we want to see for
example the Delta or a deviation between
one on the other or only the weeks when
they deviate somehow but but the the
statistical methods are not going to
complicate this individual analysis of
which matrix or measurement which
measurements affect which metrics for
example there's some I if I see some
measurements are all kind of dependent
for this metric we might not get another
another geometric do you do any analysis
not in not in that right now because
well we tried that but it didn't really
work out because the models were
basically too complex so here's the
graph theory to draw a graph of which
metrics are dependent on what but the
model were too complex and we couldn't
really get any meaningful results yeah
so we use much simpler you know PCA and
just statistics and then if like things
cuz your model is only as good as your
interpretation of it so you can
interpret those comments grabs them
exactly that's why we for example also
in this don't really go to deplane you
know or your networks but we prefer
models like decision trees or basically
decision trees which can provide their
own interpretation why they classify a
specific line as a deviation and why not
so that we could use this idea as a
input to training if it's a false
positive or as a understanding that okay
we are missing a feature in our in our
in our model so that we need to add
something so that this line does not
recognize get recognized as a false
positive
and what neural network that's really
difficult the thing is also that for
neural networks and a more complex model
I mean you need to have really really
huge data sets right and you cannot
really expect an architect to sit down
the attack you know seven million lines
of code which lines have violations or
not so you know three hundred and six
hundred lines of code is probably max
what you can ask someone to help you
with tagging so we need to have a model
that you can trace back and to
understand that if V for example T the
model gives you a false positive why is
this a false positive how should I
provide a counter example to to teach
the model in a better way and you cannot
do that with a black box with models at
a black box
I hope that helps
and all other questions with okay thank
you very much thank